thanks so I might have uh as often
happens with these sorts of things bit
off more than I can not necessarily chew
but at least digest and there's a few
things that I had promised to do in the
abstract that I won't be doing uh but
maybe we can do in the Q a like working
through examples and the paper isn't
completely finished so there'll be Parts
where I'm just summarizing as often
happens it's also ballooned longer than
could easily be completely red so the
beginning point is thinking about our
human nature and as human beings you
know we inquire about this as well as
developing and deforming our nature and
living it out and arguing about it so
the the paper itself is um I won't even
say it's necessarily exegetical it's
more just putting together a bunch of
passages and then providing some
connections and commentaries and then
we'll have a little bit of comparison to
Plato and the stoic philosopher
Epictetus on this so early in book one
of Aristotle's politics there's a short
passage of central importance for
understanding the complex nature of
human beings Aristotle is just earlier
sketch for us the development of human
communities ranging from the household
through the village to the city-state
noted different teleologies for these
and asserted the human being is that the
human being is the political or social
Animal by nature and then he tells us
why human being is a political animal
more than any bee or other gregarious
animal is clear for as we say nature
does nothing in vain and human being
alone of the animals possesses logos so
in the context of this passage we
typically translate this as speech or
language but I just leave it in the
original Greek to preclude narrowing the
sense of the term we do want to keep in
mind it's full of range of meaning
encompassing not just possession and use
of communication but also our capacity
and instances of reasoning and then he
draws a distinction between different
modalities of communication other
animals possess voice phonet and this
allows them to indicate a reference more
literally to use or make a sign to each
other of the pleasurable and the and the
painful as he notes their nature has
progressed to the extent that they have
sensation istasen of the painful and the
pleasurable and to be able to Signal
these by signs to each other and we
might of course view these capacities to
feel pain and pleasure and communicate
these with others or there's their kind
is present to greater or lesser degree
among the many things falling in the
animal kingdom coming back to human
beings we can ask what wider scope
possessing logos in addition to phone a
yields to human beings Aristotle tells
us
logos is oriented towards indicating the
useful and the harmful the likewise the
right and the wrong
for this is what is distinctive idion of
human beings by comparison to the other
animals alone having perception isasin
of the good and the bad and the just and
the unjust and the other moral qualities
and it is sharing Koinonia in these that
produces the household and the cities
passage referenced earlier so there's a
lot to unpack in this and more to
connect up with other important
discussions within Aristotle's Corpus so
at this point let us confine ourselves
to three main points first we should
note that analogously to phonate logos
allows the human being to both register
or literally apprehend or perceive and
to communicate about a range of matters
second those explicitly referred to In
this passage include the be pleasurable
and the painful the useful and the
harmful the right and the wrong the good
and the bad and then Aristotle extends
this to all the others rackham's
translation adds the term moral
qualities not there in the original
Greek but that strikes me as a needed on
point and helpful gloss and then
Aristotle asserts that we human beings
share in or have partnership in these
and this is what makes or produces human
communities
where else in Aristotle's work do we
find him deliberately distinguishing
ranges of moral qualities from each
other in similar matters well in Nico
McCain ethics book two discussion of
pain and Pleasures relevance to moral
virtue and vice he tells us there are
three matters that are the motives of
choices
and three matters that are the motives
of avoidances these are the noble the
useful and the pleasurable and they're
opposites the base the harmful and the
painful so not exactly the same list he
goes on to tell us that with respect to
all of these the good person who agathos
is likely to get these matters right and
the bad person kakos is likely to get
these matters wrong so notice that he
again references four distinct sets of
opposed moral values three of which are
matters and motives for basic functions
of practical reasoning decision and
action and one of which is applied
directly to persons book five of Nico
McCain ethics is devoted entirely to
clarifying Notions of and distinguishing
modalities of justice and Injustice
another of these paired opposite moral
values in that book Aristotle will bring
in some other opposed pairs of moral
qualities most notably the good and the
bad and the useful and the harmful and
since Justice in the sense of complete
virtue encompasses the virtues in
relation to others one could make a case
that at least that modality of Justice
involves the noble and the base other
opposed Concepts play Central roles as
well the equal and the unequal the
lawful and the unlawful and the
voluntary and involuntary
book six of the nick of McCain ethics
centered from the beginning on an
another important set of values the true
or the true and falsity or the false and
Aristotle notes that in the theoretical
or speculative domain in which we're
unconcerned with action or production
doing well or badly is just a matter of
attaining Truth or falsity very
interesting feature of Aristotle's
account however is that he extends truth
into practical and productive domains so
in book six he this is framed in terms
of practical truth
which introduces several additional
components he tells us that in the
sphere of Desire or affectivity
Pursuit an avoidance correspond to
affirmation and denial in the sphere of
the intellect he also clarifies the
distinctive human goodness we call
virtue requires that the choice racist
be structured or guided in three ways
the principle or Reason the logo must be
true the desire affectivity must be
right or straight and desire affectivity
must pursue the same things to out of
that principle or Reason affirms notice
that these same things could be read as
the same particular concrete matters or
they could be more abstract moral values
or anything in between
there are two other things to highlight
in this section of book six the first
one is rather General he tells us there
are three things in the sole most
determinative with respect to action and
Truth perception is thesis intellect
news and desire affectivity or axis he
then says that
perception Is Not An Origin or principle
of action evidenced by the fact that
animals possess it but don't share in
action proxies they don't participate in
it like we do and the second one adds
more to the picture of Truth or action
Aristotle writes the cause of action is
choice and the cause of choice is desire
or affectivity and reasoning directed to
some n logos hohenica tinos so choice is
not without intellect or thought nor is
it without moral Habit in his analysis
of friendship in book eight Aristotle
distinguishes between as we all know
three main types and motives for
friendship He suggests we should begin
by distinguishing what can be loved or
liked and This falls into three main
categories namely what is good agathon
what is pleasant and what is useful
there
we should note as well Aristotle points
out that friendship and Justice are
concerned with the same sorts of matters
and uses the term Koinonia with in that
discussion
another important text third one for us
to turn to is the art of rhetoric
discussing the scope usage and moral
status of rhetoric Aristotle makes
several key points one of these is quite
General against the common criticism
that a person who makes unjust use of
such a faculty of speech may do a great
amount of harm he points out that the
same objection can apply just as well to
all the other Goods with the exception
of virtue and especially to those things
that are most useful such as strength or
health or wealth or strategy when these
these just just as these when justly
used may be of the greatest benefit when
they're unjustly used they can cause
harm then he also notes that rhetoric is
similar to dialectic in terms of its
range it's not confined to one single
domain of subjects but like dialectic is
of General application and we might want
to remind ourselves of a related Point
Aristotle makes in the topics book one
where he distinguishes between
ethical physical and logical matters and
he notes that they have different kinds
of propositions and problems we could
say different uses of logos and distinct
opposed qualities are involved in them
there's two additional discussions from
book one of The rhetoric I think are
useful one of these is the tripartite
distinction Aristotle makes about the
means of persuasion there are three
kinds of means of persuasion furnished
through discourse DIA to logo some of
them are in the moral character of the
speaker some are in the hearer being
placed in a certain State of Mind others
are in the discourse itself through it's
displaying something or appealing to
display something and these are the
well-known and often invoke three main
modes ethos logos and pothos and we
should note that Aristotle criticizes
earlier writers for only paying
attention to pothos but not logos and
Athos
and you know he says that we need to be
able to follow logical reasoning or more
literally synergizing
they also have to study characters and
virtues you need to understand the human
emotions and how these these things work
and the discussion culminates in an
important connection made between
rhetoric and not only dialectic but also
ethics and political science
demonstrating a kind of continuity
between these another particularly
important discussion for these moral
qualities is Aristotle's distinction
between the three main types of rhetoric
he differentiates these along several
lines the first of which is the kind of
audience persuasive discourse is being
aimed at and so we get three kinds of
rhetorical speeches deliberative
forensic and epidectic each of these
lines up neatly with a time as well a
pair of actions and an end deliberative
speech is oriented towards future
actions it involves exhorting and
dissuading the listeners persuading them
towards doing or endorsing something or
away from that it's end or rather the
values it's centered by are the useful
and the harmful
forensic speech is focused on the past
and involves accusing and defending and
the values it focuses upon are the just
and the unjust the Decay on
epidectic speech is primarily about the
present but as Aristotle notes it can
also involve the other two times it
involves praising and blaming or
criticizing and the values that it is
about are the noble and the base the
kalon and ice cream
Aristotle does concede these three sets
of moral values are not exclusively
associated with these three types of
rhetoric so deliberative rhetoric while
concerned with the useful and harmful
may bring in considerations of the just
and the unjust or the noble and the base
but as he says these are included as
accessory in reference to this
there is one other text that we want to
bring up or at least one book of it
and that is the already mentioned topics
and the reason for adding that work into
this mix is that book three is not only
focused on ethical argumentation
but explores a set of topics centrally
important for moral life and these moral
qualities what we can broadly call
comparison preference or prioritization
between different general or specific
things bearing moral qualities to be
sure Aristotle explores this comparative
Dimension and detail as he sets out and
suggests reasoning topics and subject
matters in rhetoric book one the topics
book three frames these matters from the
start in terms of what what is more
Choice worthy or preferable
or the better of two or more things
baltion doing a player known and he
notes that the inquiry there doesn't
focus on things that are widely
different and easy to choose between we
don't need help with that but on those
that are closer together and about which
we have to work a bit more to determine
which would be better those things that
are controversial
a bit later on in book three he
references these comparis as comparisons
and notes that the common places are
topoi that he's provided are also useful
for showing something as worthy of
choice or avoidance per se he provides a
number of ways one can or should argue
in many of the examples he and employs
bear on what is good or just or Noble or
the Opposites of them
among these ways are what is more
lasting what a prudent person a right
law are those skilled in a discipline
would choose what is worthy of more
worthy of choice for its own sake what
is good absolutely what is an ends or a
means closer to an end we can go on and
on and on there's a whole bunch of these
interesting considerations for practical
reasoning
so after this brief excursis through
passages drawn from these Aristotelian
texts let's take a moment to consider
the ranges of moral values that have
recurringly appeared in them
uh there's two things I'd like to do
here one is simply to note the
associated terminology Aristotle uses
for each of these ranges of values the
second is to point out the breadth of
meaning and reference each of these
moral quality terms Encompass so
consider the useful and the harmful the
sumferon and blaberon Aristotle uses
these terms frequently but they're not
the only ones he employs for the
positive he also uses chrysimon and
ophelion
the opposite of the useful the harmful
is invoked less often and doesn't appear
to be replaced by synonyms but instead
gets particularized through terms that
signify ways of being harmful or
hindrances or counterproductive or
leading to bad things Aristotle is also
pretty consistent in using the paired
opposites of pain and pleasure or the
painful and the pleasurable he doesn't
make much use of of synonymous terms
except in terms of like enjoyment or
stuff like that I will point out as a
side note that in later Hellenistic
accounts of moral philosophy we do see a
shift from speaking of Lupe and the
luparon to using other terms like ponos
and agedon
Aristotle also tends to use Decon and
ADI cone pretty consistently without
shifting to other synonymous terms and
he uses cologne and Ice thrown in a
similarly consistent manner
um we see more terms ranged over when it
comes to the good and the bad the
agathon and Cocoon we have of course
virtue and vice terms coming from them
the latter of which is sometimes
replaced by mokheria or poneria uh
spudios is used quite a bit as a term
denoting a good person and there's a
variety of other terms applied to bad
people for example poneros right and
moving on from noting various words
Aristotle uses what about the range and
the richness of meaning of these terms
for these opposed moral qualities
none of these are remotely univical
terms consider what goes into being
useful or advantageous we have a wide
vocabulary synonyms for that in English
ranging from expedient to helpful
beneficial salutary we sometimes think
of the useful as possessing whatever
value it has its distinct mode of
goodness solely because it leads to or
is a means for or produces something
that is actually good to things we
genuinely value for their own sake but
you know within the domain of the useful
we'll often encounter things that are
useful because they conduce in some way
to other things that are just useful
themselves and for some people in our
broader culture and I think we probably
also see this in ancient Greek culture
things in people that are useful
sometimes take on this Aura of sort of
self-evident goodness as well
in his books Aristotle points out that
pleasure and the pleasant and their
opposites provides a pretty wide range
human beings can enjoy value desire
pursue and procure a vast variety of
Pleasures similarly they can dislike and
avoid many different things as pains or
painful some of these are mainly bodily
others mental or psychical Aristotle
recognizes some of the things people
think are pleasurable and painful are so
just because of habituation or
assumptions that they make the Pleasant
Hope of retaliation and anger for
example he also views some Pleasures as
better some is worse some genuinely
Pleasant at least for the good developed
persons others is only apparently
Pleasant which is kind of a funny thing
to say
to realize that the just and the unjust
another range are complex encompassing a
number of distinct sometimes overlapping
complementary or opposed meanings we
only have to look at Nick and McCain
ethics book six
where he discusses among others legal
justice Justice's complete virtue
distributive justice rectificatory
justice reciprocity and equity in the
politics one point Aristotle makes
multiple times is how people get what is
just partly right and partly wrong
typically by focusing on their own
legitimate perspective and ignoring that
of others in their Community he also
tells us in book five that both Justice
and Injustice are equivocal terms these
are clearly there are clearly multiple
manners in which a person in Action a
situation or a relationship can be just
or unjust
the difficulties we experience
translating the terms cologne and Ice
thrown into English and non-misleading
or non-unduly restrictive ways should
suggest to us how wide the ranges of
meaning these moral qualities have
Beauty and beautiful and ugly honorable
and shameful Noble and base fair and
foul are just some of the common
translations
um and it's not just an English thing as
well as Terence Irwin points out in a
work on the cologne and Aristotle
there's a similar complexity about how
to render this term even in Latin right
so both of these moral qualities within
this range range across what in the
present we often distinguish from each
other as aesthetic and moral domains but
they seem to be you know occupying a lot
of the same space
when we get to the agathon and kakon the
phrase good is spoken of in many ways
come natural comes naturally to mind
whether or not we accept Aristotle's
listing of categories as an adequate
account it's worth noting that he
explicitly invokes it and provides
examples of the multiple ways in which
something can be good right presumably
we can apply this to almost as many ways
maybe substance would be an issue of
being bad
so we've got this incredibly Rich range
of moral qualities right and so I think
your Indulgence in bearing with me as I
work through these passages we're likely
all familiar with highlighted several
interconnected matters involved in
Aristotle's moral theory and made this
brief excursis into terminology and
meaning we come back now to our starting
point considering as human beings with
the nature of human beings is
and you know concise definitions are
certainly useful but for answering this
kind of question I would say definitions
aren't really what we ultimately want
saying that we are animals who are
rational remains just at the level of a
formula what we want is a fuller
systematic complicated unpacking for a
lack of a better word of what's
contained in that pregnancy term logos
or logicone
in his works as Aristotle admits at
least the nick of McCain ethics he
provides us with many General outlines
which then we're expected to fill in at
times we also need to bring outlines
from one work and fit them into one from
another and what we do have or can
construct reading across Aristotle's
works is a complex robust sometimes
puzzling sometimes beset by lacunai
conception of human beings as rational
communicative social animals this
includes the entire field of moral life
itself very complex in its many
dimensions it also includes an
admittedly and complete at points
account about how Human Action works and
we might bring some of these discussions
together taking off of that Nico McCain
ethics five passes cited earlier to say
that we human beings are motivated
choose and act in terms of what we
perceive what we're what we uh are
effectively moved by or desire hearing
and I had a typo here as I was writing
this Howie logos through our mind or
intellect and I kind of like that you
know as I read through that I was like
yeah that's that's what we do we don't
just lagging we you know or Logan's in
we we use logos we're constantly
involved with it and I realize that may
sound a little high togarian but we
don't necessarily have to go down that
path and so we can say well what is it
we actually perceive all sorts of things
including those we take in through the
senses is object of sense perception
plays an important role in moral life
and in Human Action because it takes in
particulars we all know you know that
that's a key part of his moral theory
but it also grasps moral uh qualities of
matters we encounter and are engaged in
and of course people can get these wrong
and that naturally brings us to
considering other main characteristic
activities we human beings do in
relation to these moral qualities we
communicate about moral qualities in a
vast variety of manners with each other
and some human beings spend a
significant amount of their time
involved in that sort of communication
not just ethics teachers but gossipers
would be an example of that this would
involve trying to persuade each other
about them arising in some cases because
we disagree about or are in conflict
over them as Aristotle notes in rhetoric
book three teaching involves persuasion
trying to educate or inform others
rightly or wrongly is another dimension
of communication deliberating may be
done silently on one's own or even
elided over by responses rooting and
developed habits and implicit reasoning
processes but often deliberation in its
many contexts is carried out through
communication and involves other people
in its activity we may also depict
matters involving moral qualities
through our artistic Productions and our
and are we are communicated with and
perceive these moral qualities when we
engage with those projects you know when
we watch a TV show for example all of
these distinctively human activities
take place within communities or
sharings often a number of overlapping
and intersection quinonia so going back
to the politics passage let's remind
ourselves it's possessing logos
perceiving and communicating about moral
qualities sharing in these that
generates communities we also find
ourselves every General operation
already existing in complex moral
matrices involving this sharing
communicating perceiving reasoning about
and from and contesting moral qualities
not only as generalities you know what
is the good what is the beautiful but in
Myriad particular situations and
everything in between so that's the
Aristotle part
comparing Aristotle with Plato going
backwards a little bit Aristotle of
course is not the first ancient Greek
thinker to distinguish and focus on
these sets of opposed moral qualities
they come up consistently in the
euthyphro The Credo and the Fado where
they're mentioned in conjunction with
each other the three recurringly
referenced pairs of moral qualities are
the just and the unjust the good and the
bad the noble and the bass these are
what it is that gods and human beings
disagree about in ways that are
difficult to resolve thereby ending up
in Conflict feeling and being being
driven by anger and hatred with each
other these also come up in The Credo
where Socrates suggests The Credo that
they continue listening to or honoring
good rather than bad opinions which
derive respectively from the wise and
the foolish who is the wise the expert
the person who understands moral
qualities namely the just in the unjust
the base and the noble the good and the
bad this is the person who in the truth
in these matters of just things and
Noble things and good things and uh
they're opposites who is in the truth so
it's important from Socrates perspective
to live well and that means living nobly
and justly we return to these three
ranges of value in the Fatal where the
discussion of philosophies uh connection
with the forms Socrates references
Justice itself and nobility or beauty
and goodness
saying we don't grasp these here's a
different important difference we don't
grasp these through ice thesis the
senses of the body they're an impediment
but through through pure thinking which
allows us to view them as what they
genuinely are
looking at semius's argument Socrates
narrates his turn away from engaging
with natural questions and and exaggerus
is unsatisfying account towards a
approach more metaphysical and moral at
the same time by making a new start
focusing on beauty itself on goodness
and greatness and all the others once
again we see Kai to Allah panta the good
and the bad the beautiful or Noble the
ugly and the base the just and the
unjust are referenced over and over
again throughout Plato's dialogues in
the gorgeous for example the namesake
rhetor tells Socrates rhetoric is the
art of persuasion in the courts of Law
and other assemblies and what does it
persuade about the just and the unjust
um
Socrates of course gets them to admit
the art and its user produce persuasion
that is merely a belief of a matter of
belief or opinion not knowledge or
instruction and he also controls
gorgeous into expounding what else
rhetoric deals with namely any of the
matters Germaine to the Lesser Arts the
rhetorician can speak about and two
sorts of examples uh clearly deal with
the range of value Aristotle identified
with the liberative rhetoric the useful
and the harmful that's building the
walls of Athens and getting a reluctant
patient to submit to their Physicians
treatment and so presumably we can
interpret gorgeous as thinking that
rhetoric also deals with the beautiful
or Noble or the uglier base and this
isn't guesswork because Socrates will
shortly criticize gorgeous art and
portrayal of its practitioners and he
asks whether the rhetorician ignorant of
all the other Arts whose matters he
nevertheless speaks and produces
persuasion about isn't also as ignorant
of the just and the unjust the base and
the noble and the good and the evil when
it comes to any subject of the rhetor
actually know anything about what is
good and evil base or Noble just or
unjust in them and the answer is
negative so this means that if the
student of rhetoric is to understand
these matters they better bring that
understanding from somewhere else as we
learn a little bit later in the dialogue
Socrates also thinks rhetoric is not
only prone to being appropriated for
Injustice but is itself an ignoble or
base art because it's a kind of flattery
right it's it's so it's it's already
within those ranges
threaded throughout Plato's dialogues we
see a central motivating concern for
determining and knowing teaching and
learning deciding and acting upon what
the good and the bad the just and the
unjust and the noble and the base are
Perhaps it is the case that Justice
itself or the form of Justice isn't
ultimately the same thing as the form of
the good referenced in the republic or
beauty and the Symposium which are
arguably the same but we can say that
for Plato there's certainly considerable
overlap between instances of the just
and the noble and the good and
presumably they're opposites as well
Aristotle at times points out similar
interconnections but seems to maintain
stronger distinctions or
differentiations between these
modalities than does Plato and there's
three other important differences to
highlight here when it comes to moral
values
the first is that Aristotle events is
much less suspiciousness than Plato
often does about the positive values of
pleasures and the pleasant pleasure
Pleasant things pleasure and the
pleasurable are genuinely good for
Aristotle the pleasant pleasure is not
the good as such and there are higher
better more satisfying goods than just
what is pleasant but you know it is it
is a good another important difference
concerns the useful and the harmful
again Aristotle frames the useful is a
genuinely positive modality or a range
of value though its goodness is tied to
its being useful or something that
ultimately possesses a different kind of
value and as he points out many things
that possess or bear these higher things
are useful the higher values are also
useful The Virtuous friend will tend to
be useful and it would be reductive to
Hazard that in Plato's Works he always
interprets whatever is genuinely useful
as so because it's either good or Noble
or just and similarly whatever's harmful
is so precisely because it's evil base
or unjust but that does seem to be on
the whole how he typically treats the
useful and the harmful and then a third
important difference stems from an
opposed pair of values we see Plato
occasionally discussing an Aristotle
seemingly unconcerned with in at least
the ethical political works in the
euthyphro the discussion aims to
determine the nature of the Holier the
pious and the Unholy or impious and the
terms there used are tahosion
and then you said
and Socrates tries to steer their
discussion towards one in the many
instances of the Holy and Unholy is the
forms of both
autodeskinaide he says another
interesting dialogue in this respect
would be the Pythagoras right in which
we find added to the usual Fork Cardinal
platonic virtues the fifth which is
piety or Holiness so those are some
important differences I think and then
if we want to bring a stoic thinker into
the consider into the conversation we
can make some interesting points of
comparison between that school and that
of Aristotle like Aristotle the stoics
think there is an intrinsic connection
between human nature as rational
um
or is it I just lost my
here we go uh rational and is social and
political one can legitimately draw a
difference between Aristotle's focus on
the polis as the central Locus for
community and his stark contrast between
Greeks and barbarians which would
condemn nearly all of us I imagine and
the stoic emphasis on cosmopolitanism
the universal community of human beings
and the gods mentioned by Seneca Marcus
Aurelius and Epictetus but if we read
attentively in stoic literature we see
them just as concerned with how we live
act and relate as social beings within
the smaller communities of the family
the city the nation and a number of
other groups organizations and
institutions like how do you behave
yourself at the theater you know the
stoics like platonus and aristotelians
or virtue ethics ethicists who develop
rich and robust accounts of practical
reasoning desire and affectivity
deliberation and decision choice and
commitment moral evaluation and
development and Human Action the
language they employ sometimes differs
in significance or functions according
to particular terms great example of
this would be thumos stoics use it to
mean one specific kind of anger
Aristotle in his school use it as
alternately as a synonym for or gay and
to note one of three modes of
affectivity Plato and his many
interpreters take it to be one of three
parts of the human soul which happens to
get angry right the stoics routinely
reference and employ those five main
paired moral qualities that we see these
other schools and thinkers using the
good and the bad the just and the unjust
the noble and the base the pleasurable
and the painful the useful and the
harmful
um
contrary to Cicero's suggestion that
when it comes to these matters
differences between plateness or
acetylia and the stoics are merely
linguistic there is a very important
difference between them this comes from
the stoic doctrine of the indifference
which is admittedly complex and in Parts
paradoxical but which can be briefly
summarized here there are some things
that are genuinely good and some things
that are genuinely bad and then in
addition to them there are things that
are neither genuinely good or bad but
indifferent not making a difference to
the happiness or Misery the goodness or
Badness of a human being the vast Realm
of the indifference is further divided
into those involving or providing
positive value called preferred and
those bearing negative value called
rejected of the five main pairs of moral
qualities we've been looking at the
stoics placed three of these within the
domain of genuine goodness or Badness
the good and the bad obviously along
with the noble and the bass and the just
and the unjust
in the works of stoics and
interpretations of their doctrines these
three sets of moral qualities are
closely connected with each other the
pleasurable and the painful the useful
and the harmful stoics explicitly frame
as ranges of preferred and rejected
indifference by contrast these don't
lack all value but the value they have
lies below the threshold of genuine
goodness and Badness
how we human beings use regard
prioritize interpret indifference is
important for stoics the value the
virtues and vices often bear upon these
and stoics strive to get themselves and
others to rightly identify prioritize
choose and pursue the genuinely good as
opposed to guiding their lives and
Decisions by considerations of the
pleasant and the painful or the useful
and the harmful
the late stoic Epictetus explicitly
introduces another set of interesting
considerations about the beginning and
function of philosophy and activity he
like many others views as the art of
Life a development of the human person
ideally everyone would engage in but
which tends to be ignored by most people
and these turn on a concept that seems
to originate with the epicureans but
gets appropriated by the stoics that of
prolapsis often translated as
preconception or general conception so
let's note just three things Epictetus
says here the first is all of us human
beings possess and use these
preconceptions but most of us tend to
get them wrong a good bit of the time
and this happens when we apply them to
particulars which could mean screwing up
in concrete cases but also could involve
getting them generally and commonly
wrong
the second thing is that the set of
preconceptions we have as preconceptions
don't conflict with each other or
contradict each other
but they can be in contradiction when we
apply them to particulars or specifics
and he goes so far as to say most of our
human problems uh lie in the in the
failure to properly apply these then the
third is philosophy itself is a very
different origin for Epictetus than it
does for Plato or Aristotle it has its
origin in noting the difference the
disagreements between human beings and
the work of philosophy involves
clarifying these preconceptions so among
these preconceptions are a number of
opposed pairs for example what is up to
us and what is not up to us famously
labeled in the present the dichotomy of
control an idea by the way that's
already there in Aristotle and Nico
McCain ethics book three
um what other things count as
preconceptions so consider this brief
Passage
who does not admit that the good to
agathon is beneficial some Ferron and
choice worthy heider tone and that we
should seek and pursue it in every
circumstance and who Among Us doesn't
assume that what is just Toady Kion is
Honorable cologne and appropriate Prepon
uh so we already see all these moral
qualities being being talked about there
and related to each other there's other
relevant examples of preconceptions
within epictetus's work in addition to
these indications of four of the five
sets of moral values or qualities we've
devoted so much discussion to the
pleasant and the painful is clearly
among them the endurable and unendurable
the choice worthy and it's opposite the
appropriate and the inappropriate what
is in accordance with Duty what's
contrary to it these are just a few
important for moral life so let's close
by noting another set of preconceptions
argued about or examined in in book one
chapter two the reasonable eulogon and
unreasonable ah logon
Epictetus explicitly addresses himself
to the logicone zone and notes the
importance of Education or paidea which
allows us to learn how to apply these
preconceptions of the reasonable and the
unreasonable as well as the others in
harmony with nature he adds that judging
what is reasonable and unreasonable
requires making use of valuations not
only of external things but also of what
is connected to each person's proper
character or role the proced upon that
he talks about quite a bit and so we can
see by comparison that in each of these
uh let's call them Traditions these
moral qualities are incredibly important
and a lot of our moral life consists in
trying to figure our way out you know
through mistaken conceptions of these
we're constantly getting these these
wrong but Aristotle seems to take this
just to bring this to a close as being
you know what it means to be a rational
being to uh be in communities where we
share in these we argue about these we
can test these we learn about these we
deliver deliberate about them and I I
would say that I think this is a really
important Insight on his part and so
I'll just close there
[Applause]
yeah and this needs a lot of work so I'm
looking forward to
critical feedback
yeah
so I like I love the way you
you throw that connection between logos
and the different horror qualities and I
think it looks like the logos is Unified
to say that the more quality is higher
expressions of logos or
authorization of logos in different
aspects so is there a Unity of Virtues
or
sorry
I mean I having logos makes it possible
for us to go beyond the other animals
and however we want to translate I
stasis you know registering perceiving
grasping and then communicating about
these but I don't think that they're all
like I mean they're all part of logos in
the sense that like we can reference
them through logos we can think about
them
um but they're for you get the idea that
for aerosol they're they're irreducible
to each other you know
um so explicitly right yeah I mean and
he he never says like all of them
together in one place in one text as far
as I know but
um he's always distinguishing them right
but then he'll he'll also like correlate
them like you know yeah of course the
just is useful in a certain sense you
know or uh for animals
so they perceive some of the moral
qualities right the pleasant and the
painful but now here's an interesting
question that we don't go into do they
register the pleasant and the painful or
do they signal it to each other in the
ways that we do we certainly overlap to
a certain extent like you know think
about your pets and how they like to
cuddle with you and they see cuddling as
a good thing because it's Pleasant and
perhaps comforting
but I don't know that my cat or dog let
alone lower animals like somebody's like
I am going to cuddle my snake or my
spider
they're not getting remotely out of it
what what we are and I'm I'm actually
you know this is a bit of a digression
I'm willing to say that ancient
philosophers were too rigid in
um
how they understood the break between
human beings and whatever else is
rational like gods or stuff like that
and then the other animals you know I'm
willing to say that um when we talk
about these higher animals like
cetaceans and elephants and perhaps you
know corvids that maybe they participate
in a lot more than
than ancient thinkers did in this this
range of you know uh problem solving and
appreciating things in perhaps a moral
perspective but they they don't do it to
the extent that we human beings do I
mean we're constantly jabbering about
this kind of stuff right most most of
the time wrongly you know I mean that's
what social media basically is most of
the time is people making value
judgments about one thing or another and
then expressing it you know
yeah I was increased by a point you made
this very briefly I'd like to hear more
about uh and that was that Plato
the pious and envious
yeah to a certain extent contrasted in
with Aristotle in that respect at least
with the ethical works right I mean okay
um
and Aristotle is
right right and I'm just wondering
[Applause]
if the relation of
humans to the gods yeah yeah
I would say have a very significant
place in America so I'm just wondering
well how great the difference between
player and aerosol so so here's what I
would say about that
um
you know in the Youth of frog
uh piety isn't just a form of justice
that winds up leading to another Opera
right so I don't know that that's
yeah I mean that that could be it yeah
so I I I do want to hold out that it's
not
um something reducible to the other
modalities that and it intersects with
them but isn't exactly the same
I don't see it as playing that much of a
role I mean Aristotle
doesn't talk I mean if so in Nick of
McCain ethics there are a few places
where
um there are mentions of the Gods but
not an awful lot you know and when he's
talking about like the construction of
the polis and and the politics he does
say well you get all these different
officials and like some have to watch
jails and some have to be responsible
for temples but he doesn't seem to care
an awful lot about the religious life or
like about prayer or stuff like that
as as you'd you'd think
well yeah there you go yeah yeah yeah
um I mean and that's not to say that uh
you couldn't be an Aristotelian and care
about those things
a lot right
but I I just I maybe I'm
I just don't see it but maybe I haven't
read Aristotle as deeply as I need to
and looking at Lambda eight and he says
um
our forefathers and the most promoted
ages have handed down to us their
posterity and tradition in the form of a
myth that these substances are Gods the
rest of the tradition has been added
later in mythical form with a view to
the persuasion of the multitude into its
legal and utilitarian expediency they
say these dogs are in the form of men
and like some other animals and they say
other things consequent on and similar
to these we could mentioned yeah I want
to separate the first point right so
like that to me he doesn't he doesn't
believe in the gods yes like yeah
yeah
well at least
yeah at least with Plato though there's
the and the stomachs also have this too
that we can be the friends of the Gods
in we can be part of this Commonwealth
with them now that doesn't seem to
involve an awful lot of like obesians
and sacrifices and even prayer that much
right he just says it does he says he
says that he says the most important he
says well important thing about the gods
is too is to have correct beliefs about
them beliefs but there is no prayer and
Epictetus and even divination you gotta
you know he's like hey don't use
divination except in the very last
resort and he's kind of unlike the other
stoics in that respect right who at
least going by Cicero we're into
divination he's like you know anything
that you can figure out yourself handle
that yourself and then go to the gods
with that but do it kind of kind of
carefully right but there's no like you
know when we talk about somebody having
like a
prayer life or something like that
there's nothing like that in in if Titus
whereas you know in in later once later
platonism starts getting really
interested in uh the dimones and and the
gods we have some room for that right
um
but I didn't talk about that in this I
wanted to keep it simpler
did you have your hand up on I do know
can you say a little bit more about the
uh the useful the uh oh because again
there's supposed to be three different
trying to understand
to a point which is well taken that it
is a good for ourselves yeah so it's a
lesser good right I'm wondering I'm
wondering some distinctions of might be
made here okay I mean yeah
my father basically uh uh had the tools
I inherited for my father
um cleaned out his place
had all these woodworking tools which
I'm sure are very useful if I did that
stuff yeah
you know
off the Goodwill or whatever because
they're not going to be useful to me
yeah yeah
and then you have something like um uh
a skill like being able to read French
which is useful to me because I'm I'm a
scholar yeah and there's a lot of this
good stuff written in French but it
might not be useful to other people and
then you've got things like physical
strength which presumably is useful to
everybody yeah through the virtue of the
body albeit not and the lack of which is
harmful right yeah right yeah and so
presumably that's because by Nature all
of us are teleologically organized yeah
yeah
sometimes we need to lift up heavy stuff
and uh yeah and and so um thoroughly
physical stretch would be useful in that
way but the other kinds of utility would
seem to be contextual yeah I'm not sure
that you know being able to do
calculations very very quickly or or or
or virtues like that or abilities like
that would be unqualified goods for
hours well they're not unqualified right
um I mean mostly I think you're right
that most of the things
in a lower level I think you're doing
more than simply saying
for you not useful for me that's right
yeah
I mean however
um and don't mistake it for the will for
the for the uh the focal instinct sense
of
I think that's right yeah and you know
it's sort of like if we wanted to screw
around with Kant right and uh buy into
some of his stuff and then reject the
rest so you know he famously
distinguishes between these uh rules of
skill and councils of prudence and then
genuine you know uh commands of of
morality and he's he's not all that
happy about the councils of prudence
because uh who who knows what we really
need and you know it's not it's not
enough to to get us where we need to go
and we can say oh yeah well you're wrong
about that Kant you know we can say that
at least for the most part human beings
need this kind of stuff and they need
this kind of stuff and this is useful
for them and but then there's all sorts
of things that are much more qualified
even physical strength right it's kind
of funny there's this uh endless
discussion on Twitter that I it keeps
coming popping up in my stream and I am
sure it's because of who I follow about
you know how how important it is to be
jacked you know build yourself up like
those special forces guys you know or
like the Spartans and all that all this
hyper masculine stuff and then there's
always like some military personnel
point out to them guys like that don't
last a second on the battlefield because
they run out of energy real quick and
all those muscles take a lot of energy
to keep you know keep them working and
so you know the physical strength no you
could say well so maybe it's a matter of
like appropriate for this situation or
too much or stuff like that but there's
a lot of people out there who do seem to
think that the useful for them would be
as much of this as possible you know or
like if I just had a billion dollars you
know then everything would fall into
place
um well no because you can easily screw
your life up a lot of lottery winners
wind up quite unhappy you know as it as
it turns out so yeah the realm of the
useful has to be kind of I won't say
completely heterogeneous but we we would
have to make differentiations within it
and I don't I don't think there's I mean
I haven't like read everything in the
Aristotelian Corpus so maybe there's
passages somewhere where he is
doing something like that
um and and I will say too in the
rhetoric there's a lot of good
discussion of the useful and the harmful
in that part about deliberative rhetoric
right my hesitation is is that the way
you were speaking makes it sound is like
utility is an intrinsic good albeit a oh
less important one
probably a uh yeah no it's it's that uh
under certain contexts I'll put it to
you this way so it's not an intern
anything that is the useful is not an
intrinsic good by itself it's good
because it leads to something else
however it can take on an aura within a
culture within a family within a
person's life of yeah this this really
is something good even though you know
if they analyzed it carefully they would
realize oh I really just want this for
this right
does that help yeah the prime example
there is money yeah yeah exactly yeah
uh what else yeah
um I wanted to give a suggest Maybe
good
I mean very careful about what he says
about the intelligence
I mean it's not a problem
before you do what you're doing but
it'll be interesting to see what is it
could uh connotations or limitations
talking about
so the pain seemed to display many forms
of intelligence
they fly far away uh high up to get a
broader Vantage points but if they see
clouds and storms they fly back down
they have a leader and additional priors
um
amongst them on the farther edges of the
block so the leader's voice so they uh
so that the leader's voice will be heard
then the seven bound they go back to
sleep with their heads under their wings
standing on one leg he's very observant
alternative
alternating while the leader stays on
the lookout head uncovered and signals
with a cry and he sees something and I
think yeah yeah something here about
um signal signaling the language is
reasoning with science okay yeah
um
and so I I found it I believe
the cry verb is wow so it's not anywhere
closer in purpose obviously but the fact
that it is being used to communicate
functions as a kind of practical
means of
practical intelligence yeah
I think there's another really
interesting pattern unrelated to this
discussion where Arsenal talks about
um what the lion takes pleasure in when
he hears a stag right yeah so I think
this there is more complexity to the
Pleasure and Pain tissue there because
he says he's not picking pleasure in the
cry is the animal but the anticipation
of it as food yeah if I remember the
passage correctly yeah
say
a anticipating pleasure which is not
tied to just the taste of the stuff yeah
yeah
so more complex yeah and you know and if
we wanted I mean let's say we take off
on the lion example if we were thinking
about this when we put Aristotle
and other ancient thinkers to the side
and we're like what what is really going
on in
now admittedly it's we're we have to
anthropomorphize to some degree but we
could say
um
what's going on when they're they're
they're hunting right they
you know
they probably do enjoy not just the
sinking their teeth into it tasting the
blood you know anticipating I'm gonna
have a full belly but the you know the
enjoyment of the the Chase and they you
know they
um I remember when we watch I mean we
know we know so much more about animals
nowadays we ordinary schlobs because we
have you know access to YouTube and
documentaries and stuff like that we can
actually see these in in it really
interesting interest species
interactions and then even like uh
inter-species interactions like you know
seeing
um you know admittedly these are in
captivity or you know in domesticated
situations but seeing uh a panther uh
playing around with a dog you know a
Rottweiler or you know the fact that
cheetahs now have emotional support dogs
in in zoos you know and there's all this
very interesting stuff I think we have
to say that yeah they're they're psychic
life is way more complicated than the
Ancients thought or even I mentioned
Heidegger you know Heidegger's saying
you know animals don't have a world they
sure they sure as all seem to I mean
maybe not oysters right maybe not even I
don't know if a spider does or not
um what were you going to say I'm
reminded of Arabian cohort who argues
that even rocks have a world oh
interesting you know what in what sense
do they have a world like because they
have an environment that they engage
with or nothing like that yeah
yeah I mean I mean Heidegger means it in
like the sense of having Horizons and
all this kind of stuff but I mean I
think when we when we look at these uh
very interesting animal interactions or
we consider social animals like bees and
ants and stuff like that there's a hell
of a lot more going on than we gave them
credit for now does that mean we should
call them rational I I don't know you
know I mean a very minor point I live on
a farm
and when the coyotes oh
yeah
howling yeah improve their communal
bonds it's just amazing and they you
know they took down a deer back behind
their shed and feasted on it for
quite a lot of time yeah and it wasn't
for my dog barking Adam
to me the howling of it also sort of a
communal nature of
it right yeah yeah
I mean it would just kind of like
save their own food for themselves yeah
completely communal experience I mean on
that note with communication we we
didn't know until fairly recently that
elephants were communicating with each
other all the time they're just
vocalizing at ranges that we couldn't
hear that happened to transmit over
miles and miles and miles you know and
they give their trunks too their motion
of their trunks and the kind of science
all right yeah yeah
you had syntax you had to learn syntax
yeah now I mean coming back to this can
we say that animals like
deal with the just and the unjust
probably not right but
um certainly what's good and bad for
them you know they communicate about it
they sometimes help each other out with
it you know they're they're elephants
more than they're dead that's true when
they come across an element carcass
they'll stop and sway over it yeah even
that of a even that of a stranger yeah
what's up
oh interesting I didn't know that
yeah
yeah go ahead
oh
oh hello hey thank you thank you very
much I have some remarks and comments uh
all are associated related to uh to the
first part of their paper about uh
Hospital
why why I have some kind of impression
that because he is making a struggle
actually you follow high level at some
point
is a rational animal having locals in
the sense that means only only human
beings can touch the objects that is the
good bad
just and yes okay
other hand however animals cannot touch
the offices for example a dog cannot
distinguish between
poison and medicine and now poison poop
sometimes for the bad food or a good
food
so sometimes a dog will be killed yeah
yeah eating something bad okay this is
how it was invitation at some point I I
have such a kind of importance that you
follow that this first remarks second uh
you'll see that the the audio guess is
this outside virtues in the context of
your system okay there's opposite what
use is a basis for communication human
communication uh I understand I
understand your your focus is actually
unpractical philosophy
yes yes but I I would like to say this
is not only such kind of objective
not only the basis for for our activity
communication but also for doing
Philosophy for example says okay in the
career in the theoretical activity
the human being stressed for something
uh for the truth yeah yeah we cut we can
get the truth if and only if we come
first of all distinguish because
something good at the truth and Force
Mode
in the Practical activity we aim at
something good
if we can we can get something they can
get a good thing uh only if weigh very
very distinguish between the good and
bad yeah yeah
so I see I would like to say the the
outside of work use an automatic basis
for practical communication but also for
uh activities of human beings
well I am saying that it is we we use
this all the time of the activities to
judge them to you know decide what we're
going to do to
prioritize and but I think yeah you know
one of the things with Aristotle
that I've always found
um
problematic
is in the you know the in the Practical
let's call them the Practical treaties
these are ethical political treaties
right he'll sometimes say things like ah
you know this isn't about like you know
knowing a lot of things this is
ultimately this is about action and
that's what we're interested in and then
you're like well why the hell did you
write a whole book about it you know
um you know why why and so take the
politics for example you know I mean
there's not he doesn't address every
single possible issue or problem and he
is clearly concerned with you know
what's going on in the the police in his
Society
um but you can say you know this is also
a theoretical work it's not just a
merely practical work the the kind of
overlap with each other and we're
talking about this earlier I don't
remember if it was at this lunch or a
previous one
uh you know theoretical activities are
also practically oriented all the time
right I mean it sometimes in ways that
are extrinsic like oh I need to write a
grant so I got some money so I I can
actually afford to work on this right so
I better convince
Peoria is a it's a special case of axis
yeah I mean Heidegger is saying that I
think there's others who are saying that
as well you know American pragmatism is
uh notorious for making claims like that
too but yeah I think I think you're
right yeah
um
now if if what I've done is essentially
just you know
um retrace Heidegger
that's a mistake on my part but that's
okay I guess you know
better than retracing Descartes Maybe
any other questions or we might wrap up
a little earlier did you have one yeah
comments so maybe we can say that
anything that has a relation to the
world
oh I was reaching out to the world
Beyond yourself I mean no because I mean
an oyster does interact with the world
right and even like register presumably
something analogous to pain and how it
creates the Pearl you know it tries to
secrete the things but we don't want to
say it's got logos do we no I mean not I
I mentioned
it's a very broad sense but okay I would
be could you have awareness without
having some degree of problems yes
animals yeah yeah
but wait because of course that we are
we're thinking all of us in a very broad
sense because the use of imagination is
associated
we are not talking about logos in the
that's a specific difference of the
human being trying to to understand
because if you go to the
store uses the word leggings
the artists
no sense yeah and animals have common
sense no and of course they don't have
Vegeta is
the other one in
estimative in the medieval times so of
course I'm broadly but it was like a big
one I think it was suggested by some of
the comments here that it looks like in
a way relation is is two ways yeah I
have awareness but I don't have any sort
of
the same any sort of logos
that's my point I mean I know it's very
Broad and I don't I mean we could also
if we want to like shift into like a
theistic framework we could say well
everything has logos in the sense that
like
whatever it is God made it and implanted
it with again whatever it is it's some
you know
it's it's pattern it's blueprint it's
it's stuff and then we can discover that
in it but I think then we're in such a
different
um
not just stimulus response yeah
supposedly propositional okay
but
yeah I think it is so that's that's a
great place maybe to end
um oh
I
I think that's something for that right
because
it began with this
man is more important Political Animals
than these yeah
[Music]
um near voice has been an indication a
pleasure of pain is therefore found in
other animals
hour of speech is intended in set forth
to experience right
yeah
right my tlg is super small I'm sorry
I'm trying to fight against my politics
passenger
but it's interesting that this has
expedient inexperience right that the
animals do
and that's kind of what that's yeah in
the history of animals he's showing how
they're able to show
a kind of practical intelligence so
I only have these passages because I
give this to my students as an exercise
to figure out you know how do we make
sense of animal intelligence so he talks
about the intelligence of Hedgehog it
talks about diesels
um yeah
and avoid the harmful too
yeah yeah and there are many instances
that he observes of this kind of
behavior I mean yeah yeah the good and
the just yet
certainly have
Behavior which he observes as indicating
awareness of the expedient yeah and we
and we also see animals
um in the realm of the useful and
harmful learning from watching each
other like
um well great example of this is uh cats
there are certain things that they need
to like learn from other cats how to do
well they can sometimes discover them on
their own but like how to kill a mouse
right the kittens need to observe
another cat doing that or else they'll
just mess around with it and it's very
gruesome for the mouse because they
don't break its neck right away
the verb queen of mine
so even plants have creases
but they have green or mine
will say that
Aristotle
apply creases to I mean in the to me as
Plato Plato gives ice Aces to plants
plants don't have anything my point my
opponent is that that would be an
example of what I was trying to say that
it's not simply perception or just I
mean there is a sort of discerning or
whatever we want to say that's that's a
sort of relation to the world that is
not it's not simply being hit or
receiving things he's responding to it
yeah yeah if that responding to the
degree of locus
for kindness puts all of these things on
the Continuum rather than
a civil you know like landscape you know
yeah
way down from intellect itself down to
the Earth
because every life is a thought one of
the defense thought another the life of
plant is a growth yeah
and so on and I really don't think he's
being unarris to you in doing that
do you find that does Aristotle say that
that's what kindness does no yeah I
think it's a legitimate and extension of
development of Aristotle rather than a
going against that
there's Apostles of the history of
animals which
uses ethereal Continuum but like not for
the old difference it's not it's like
it's like the law of life and it's about
the law of continuity but uh said by
Aristotle right uh
so I go by memory in the nature like
everything
changes continuously very slowly from a
species to another
foreign
it's not just all driven by
you know programmed instincts right uh
yeah yeah
all right we are significantly a little
over
well thanks very much
[Applause]